Let's go through it together.
Starting from sentence, I can get to subject verb.
One possible subject is students.
One possible verb is think.
We saw this one before. This is definitely in the language of the grammar.
However, students teachers is not.
That's 2 subjects in a row, and there's just no way to get there
starting from sentence.
We can turn sentence.
We can rewrite it into subject followed by verb,
so we can match students at the beginning, but teachers is not a verb.
There's just no way to make this happen.
Students write, this is one of our subjects, this is one of our verbs.
That looks good. Teachers think.
Teachers think, that's a subject followed by a verb.
That looks good. Teachers write.
That also looks good. Think write.
These are 2 verbs, and our rules up here say a sentence
has to be a subject followed by a verb.
This just doesn't match the pattern.
And in fact, in this particular grammar, these 4 are all of the strings in the grammar.
There are only 4 possibilities.
This grammar is perhaps not super exciting,
but we're going to get to something, many things,
much more exciting than this in just a bit.